[Music]
Joe there was some tricks you guys were
shooting in some very cold weather and
will was very helpful with that was he
not I mean there was they have rain
towers that they like took from the
groundwater in Toronto it was like icy
cold so we were all just like we were
miserable in that and then we'll had the
brilliant idea of getting in like a
bucket of like steaming hot water and
he'd get this little bucket and he's
like sneak up to people that were like
standing his shivering to death and then
you'd like pour it down there next and
you could just like seeing people
standing there and they were like it was
like it was sensual and he was going
around he was running around like a
little kid in the candy store he was
like and then it like caught on so
everybody was taking these little
buckets and like pouring on each other
it was turned like a little weird in
there the whole crew was like looking at
us get me Joe get me
[Laughter]
Joe thank you sound guys they were they
were not so happy yeah I think we were
pouring water into their microphone so
we were like y'all are like killing us
here it was very warm but you guys won't
hear any of the dies a lot of crackling
and shorting out to most of them
you